i'm sure you guys heard last night i
almost uh killed somebody because i was
sitting there having
a drink after dinner and then it was
announced that la is going to have a
mask mandate i just want to be very
clear
i'm not wearing a mask anymore period
these people are all frauds and
ridiculous buffoons gavin newsom
spent fifteen thousand dollars at french
laundry the at the height of this thing
during lockdowns
without a mask and i don't know what are
they gonna arrest me if i walk into a
store
as a young healthy person uh and try to
buy something i mean it's just
completely ridiculous
there's no science behind it that's my
thoughts um
rogan what do you think mask mandates
back in la you're in florida so you're
all right
yeah i mean we we've been mask-free for
a long time
i was unfortunately kicked out of our
recent cpac event
uh that we hosted in florida in february
because uh you know it was in a blue
county
orange county uh you know orlando which
is heavily blue
and you know governor ron de san just
got rid of the statewide mask mandate i
lived in an area where it wasn't
strongly enforced and
i went to that cpac conference i said
listen this is florida we have to set
the example we're not mask drones
i got kicked out um not by cpac by high
security
but uh you know it it's such a farce i i
don't know how they keep playing this
game
uh when you see how open florida is we
have concerts with 60
000 people and no spike in cases
so uh you know and again either the
vaccine works or it doesn't
and if they're pushing this vaccine if
so many people especially in bluer areas
have gotten the vaccine
why are they worried about what happens
to anyone else if they don't want the
vaccine that's their choice at this
point well the new meme is not that it
doesn't work but that you will get a
somehow lesser degree of covid
especially related to the delta variant
that that's what they're telling us
uh david has this all just taught you
something about human nature that
perhaps we all knew but we were afraid
to admit
yeah we we love um
we love to control others or let's say
there are some of us who love to control
others
and um and it doesn't even really matter
what uh what the the the criteria is or
or what anyone is saying it's just uh
it's it's just very simple i mean you
know the answer
my answer here is just move to florida i
mean at the at the end of the day i'm
not sure
what i'm working on down there you know
you know give me give me some time here
we move the company one thing i know
it's not easy i know it's not easy but
but this is
you know these are the these are the the
steps that have to be made you know not
everybody can
can you know just stand up on a dime and
say okay i'm leaving
but uh but everyone can begin that
conversation
at least in their in their minds and and
with their with their families and
figure out i want to be where i'm
surrounded by people who don't hate me
who don't want to um you know make me a
prisoner of these absurd mask mandates
and and you know
it's it's just it's just better here in
every way and you know what this is also
having a a salutary effect
in the sense that there are a lot of
folks millions of americans who didn't
give a damn about politics before
and they didn't understand how it could
affect their lives
and now they can and they see that
these decisions made by anusam
um versus similar decisions made by a
desantis
are worlds apart and they really do
affect their lives and this is why this
stuff
means something that's why it's
important to take part in this process
by the way i will never say anything
nice about gavin newsom and i think he
is christian bale from american psycho
but i have a feeling he's against the la
mask thing because this has to work
against him in the recall right but ron
now as the lawyer i'm gonna
i'm gonna let you finish up here and i'm
gonna put you on the spot
can you give me some legal advice if i
walk into my supermarket without a mask
and they stop me
and i say you know just an employee or a
security guard or something and says
put on your mask and i say well actually
this is against cdc guidelines it's
against california
state guidelines i'm young and healthy
and i'm just
going to walk in and buy a box of
frosted flakes i won't cough on anybody
or kill grandma
what what legal trouble could i be in at
that point like what
these mandates what legal heft do they
have
they have as much legal heft as the
supermarket in your example wants to
give them
so if you if they're going to maintain a
rule
because they're going to maybe get
pressured by the local government or
because
they're run by you know woke people or
whatever the case may be
you might have to do like david reboy
and find another place to shop
because that that is a private company
right so you don't have you don't have a
legal right to ignore the
the mask mandate in a private
environment
uh if they want to rescue on the street
if they made an outdoor mandate
then we can talk but you know we've
we've taken you know we've pushed back
on california pretty pretty heavily and
they're paying a lot of legal fees to a
lot of law firms including ours on the
on
covid related uh power grabs but
you're gonna have to choose a better
supermarket yeah ironically
because of our ridiculous progressive
d.a here in los angeles george gascon
who was the d.a in san francisco and
ruined that city
they don't arrest you right now or they
won't charge you with trespassing or
resisting arrest
so you can go you can go to the
supermarket and shoplift
if you can't go to the supermarket and
breathe